[Music]
hi hi I'm sorry hey dari nice to see you
all I work at BBC News as a web
developer in London and it's my first
time in Singapore it's a real pleasure
to be here thank you thank you for guys
from my team on the screen is a photo of
me exploring the day before this
conference in Singapore and my son fact
is that I absolutely love the weather
here everyone here seems to think I'm
weird for that but it's awesome even the
rain I love that you have warm brain
here I don't understand it but it's
awesome yes so in London I work on the
BBC News webpages so they are for
curated content to help people discover
content so what that means in practice
is that I work on pages like this so
this is the screenshot from today of the
BBC News website so on the front page in
addition to these we do like all sorts
of other kind of creations and things of
like collections of articles and content
like that so that's about me what are we
going to talk about today so the talk is
called accessibility in you first I will
talk about myself because that's kind of
fun I will talk about a little bit about
a few little stories about how I got an
interest in accessibility then I'll talk
about why do BBC News and a couple of
examples of the work we do there and
most importantly I think is getting you
all started so if you haven't started at
all so well what was great about this
conference is that earlier on on the
first day we had awesome talks showing
you screen readers and and things like
that so you probably all have a little
bit familiarity tips so hopefully I go
into other aspects of accessibility and
how you can get started if you haven't
already
so so let's get started so let me go
back a few years before I ever became a
web developer or had anything cruelly to
do with with tech as a job I was at
university in London I didn't really
think about obsessively at all to be
honest like I'm able-bodied don't have a
disability and my only current
understanding was physical accessibility
like this so this is a photo of the
entrance to one of the university
buildings on on the front side of the
photo you've got some steps and on the
other side you've got a ramp to enter
the building I was like okay cool they
saw about things so people would
wheelchairs can get in the building
great right so that's all good right
whilst I was setting there friend of
mine had a chronic illness then needed
to be able to use a wheelchair and so
they had gots user and were able to get
up like a powered wheelchair electrical
just to be able to never get round which
is cool they were able to do that and
some of the lectures that they're in and
buildings are in were able to have the
ramps and they were able to enter one
the first month after that I think they
were gonna go to the Students Union and
this is where if you don't know what
super teen is like I mean they also have
like coffee shops and things but they
also have like the offices of like the
welfare offices for students and people
who can give advice to students they
need help so like you know you need to
be accessing them and the building had
lift so this is the lift which is
awesome but it is probably you can't see
from the photo and maybe you can it's
really narrow you can probably walk in
there but and the wheelchair doesn't
can't can't enter they can enter so it's
like someone's thought about one aspect
but not reason about how they've gone to
the expense of building this whole lift
and like
organizing the whole building to make it
work for with a left not really thought
about like you know who I did all or
some things like that so it's not quite
as useful and in addition to that so
that's one building there were lectures
that were up on like the top floor and
like rickety staircases that had to be
like rearranged and things because they
hadn't considered that one of the
students might might need a special
access this and this was I thought it
was pretty frustrating I stood my friend
was my friend was pretty frustrated as a
little bit as well the fact that they
have to go to each individual lecturer
to ask them to read to change over sink
to rewrite or in the rooms and all of
that and this is like like seeing them
do that just make me realize just how
many how many barriers there are even
even from an institution that professes
to be open and accessible and in terms
of wanting to have such a range of and a
wide variety of students and dive and
talks about the diversity of its student
body so that was like my first like
major kind of thinking like there's
things need to be improved in the world
things things like even places people
that that care about will say that they
care about accessibility really need to
need to do a lot better now I'm going to
talk about something that might seem
completely unrelated family tech support
so hands up if you have ever had to be
her family text the tech support for any
family member come on come on there's
more of you than that yes yes okay very
much everyone here yes me too I
constantly whenever I call family
members they're like oh by the way how
do I update this thing yeah
yes so this is a photo of Carriger city
close to Tehran capsule over Iran where
my family's from
and yes we've got mountains would snow -
it's not just deserts and so I visit my
grandparents and extended family there
and every year or so and when I do that
and usually I get asked like oh can you
fix something which is cool so first
thing so about a few years ago or five
years ago my granddad was like right
I've heard like everyone has email I
want an email account I want to be able
to email you I was like that's cool hey
awesome I will set you up with a gmail
account because I have Gmail and pretty
much everyone has Gmail why not
and we did and then I used you know like
every day up until that moment I didn't
realize there was anything wrong with it
that's all because I was using it it
like allowed me to have everything that
I want like so many emails so many
attachments all all of the things that I
needed weather except one I had to
explain how to do things to my granddad
and I realize just how many steps there
are so so if you haven't used you email
this is a screenshot of of like what the
web interface on desktop there is Bert
read compose button in the top
I don't realize like the fact that it's
system PO I hadn't noticed that about it
since compose I'm not like new message
so compose when you put like in Google
Translate it comes up like composing
music and so it doesn't translate very
well so it's like why I don't call it
new message it's kind of like and it's
just like little things the little
language that people use in a user
interface it's like things that I
haven't really paid attention to before
I just like I learn what it did and just
ignored what it said and I like had to
explain why what composition means in
this context which is really bizarre and
have yeah okay so that's fine that's
what I mean so that's what the butter is
yeah so that's it selected
and then I was like work a woman my
daughter and I was like okay cool so now
how do I email a specific person how do
I email you to have around
like my own my aunts and things and I
was like cool I'll save all of the
everyone's like email addresses in the
contact list I use like super that's
great
I asked me how do I find them it's like
well sure you just go on this and then
you click that it's like but why do I
click the thing that says Gmail and then
behind it there's a thing that says
contacts and then behind that I click a
forum and then I fill out a form and
then it will took a mute like why are
the five steps I was like I don't know
like I just got used to it it's like
that's how I just did things I just do
that and it'll to commute said it just
like for me it just said but when a when
I had to explain it it's like multiple
stuffs like that's a lot of steps but
something that basically every person
does regularly with email right you send
emails to people in your contacts yeah
and and so I'm like my grandma's like he
like clever he does lay laws and
contracts and stuff but in these indie
sailing hehe he's buying with like
things and lots of steps but sometimes
if he doesn't view things like regularly
like he doesn't need to check his email
like five times a day to be honest so if
doesn't do mercury then he forgets
well the like the million steps are to
do the thing and so I ended up doing
oops what I ended up doing is writing
out so I had to write it out like in
Farsi so that's the language over
including little title really badly
drawn like icons of like what the
buttons do and like what would have to
do the same in and things and I really
really like okay this is a user
interface with like okay built that had
been built and people built it for their
own use cases and not really realized to
all the different steps there and it
really made me think and maybe not
necessarily at that moment but just like
thinking afterwards a lot about what
interface accessibility means so it's
not like my granddad couldn't use the
the Gmail web and basically he could
it's not like he was prevented from
using it didn't necessarily I mean he
has bad Isis I had to wear his glasses
it's not like he couldn't access the the
website the service he could it was just
that by setting up the interface like
that it just made it a chore it made it
so difficult it's I mean it made it a
pain and an annoyance so you have to go
through that and so that made me think
about about how accessibility can be
more than just given people with
disabilities access to a service it can
be ease of use as well it can be making
people's lives just like more enjoyable
by making a use of tech an enjoyable
experience and not just like a painful
list of things memorized to have to go
through so yes so that was like another
little aspects of of things I and like
fast food a bit too
so my first left web development role by
this point I had done a coding boot camp
because I knew I really wanted to do web
development but didn't really have the
specific skill scale to get a job so I
did one of those for three months and
when those intense plans and I realized
that yeah I would like to work at a
place that cares about best practices I
could learn best practices for things
and cares about accessibility and things
like that and I was really really lucky
to and now the BBC News were hiring and
if you are not aware BBC News as part of
like BBC and BBC British Broadcasting
Corporation is is partly favored and
partly funded by the UK taxpayers like
the TV licence and so it has a public
service room and so it has like a like a
legal obligation to to edge
and inform and and also be accessible to
as much of the population UK as possible
which is pretty cool and so that's why I
kind of like was really excited to be
able to work there and I remember
raising it in the interview and they
like to mention it and they they also
really like the fact that that that I
cared about accessibility as well and I
thought that was a pretty pretty good
indicator of things okay so that was
that so now I'm going to go on to a bit
more about how things how we look at
things when we talk about accessibility
at BBC and BBC News in particular which
is where I work so let's look at a high
level of what types of disabilities we
think about most people like might be
more aware of like vision impairment so
blindness or partially sighted people so
who can't and view the screen very well
or at all so you screen readers and
other assistive technologies also you
have people who are hard of hearing so
it might not be able to listen to the
audio and videos and so we require for
example captions on video content and
and transcripts of audio content that
people cognitive disabilities so so this
includes people with dyslexia or so who
have autism and then also people with
motor skills and impairments and so what
what I liked is the hearing the whole
range of understanding the well
obviously this isn't like an exhaustive
list but different groups of people with
various disabilities and understanding
the different needs was something that
we learn
initially so now I'm going to talk about
how that actually okay so that's like
maybe you some of the audience but I'm
going to talk about an actual case the B
and I'm something that is currently
being worked on at BBC so BBC wreath is
a new font font family recently built by
the design teams heard the BBC so here
on the screen is an example of the of
the serif and what I liked was reading
what the aims so okay so the aims are
distinctiveness so basically what they
wanted to do the design teams wanted to
make it a pages look distinctively BBC
so you look at them and you read the
content and it's like it feels like
different to other sites okay that's
very designee it doesn't really make
sense to me but okay that's something
that kind of goes over my head but okay
I can understand the fat like this
there's also money saving argument
because Helvetica costs a lot to license
to pay for the license so they're like
you know if we do something in house
then it's we own the license through it
so we don't need to like pay tons of
money for it but one of the three cool
I'm cool aims which I quite liked was
that it was a legibility so to ensure
that this font font family is more
legible than the existing ones that we
use okay so to make sure that happened
once they had a like an iteration of the
font that they quite liked the user
research team light they they actually
designed tonight they conducted user
research so 36 participants yeah 18 of
them with cognitive disabilities
including dyslexia autism and ADHD to
look at to do in lab viewing of websites
with the previous font so the vertical
one and the new one BBC series and seek
your feedback on what the differences
were and whether I thought it was more
legible or less legible or all of that
and this is one particular
participants the sponsor wreaths the new
font is clearer to read more spacing so
the words don't blur it takes me less
time to work out whether it's a plq I
look for tails tails on the P's and Q's
letters to see which way around it is so
the previous fonts mate made it more
difficult and BB series made it much
much more easy so what does this mean is
that yes so even the design teams are
thinking about how to make this more
legible and how to consider people with
a range of needs what's even better
about this is that if it if it is more
legible to people with dyslexia say it
becomes more legible for pretty much
everyone else as well which is pretty
cool so so that's one so BBC recently
found that's one aspect another thing is
the becoming one thing that I found out
pretty much immediately when I joined
was that we have accessibility champions
which sounds pretty like awesome right
who doesn't want to be a champion
basically anybody can be a champion and
you don't need any like accessibility
expertise to solve with you don't need
that just need a willingness to learn
which is cool started off a few years
ago and now there are over like 150
developers designers and testers across
26 teams across the BBC service in sport
and music and and news and iPlayer and
all sorts of different products there
and also internal products that facing
other developers and other journalists
and things as well and so that's a lot
of people and what what as a part of
that is that you get
we've got like the slack to slack team
so there's a sports supportive online
community it's he so if you have any
questions you like I don't know what to
do here you can you can just ask
somebody there and there is that support
which is pretty cool
one thing that I loved about is that
initially first thing I liked pretty
much on my first month I was like I want
to be one of these so I want to learn
more about accessibility
I want to be an excessively champion and
then the first thing is called what's
called tosh.0 which is like which is
quite cool because it's like it's like
it's zero it feels like there's a low
barrier to entry right it's not even
tasked when it's like zero so it's like
it's almost like you have a zero
knowledge it's fine
so I really like I wanted to share this
because I think it's a great way if you
haven't really done much like it's this
ability testing for how you can get
started so you can choose a key feature
from your product so it might be the
whole page in my view specific new
feature and you pick five standards from
the guidelines right so I'll talk about
the guidelines in a bit this is learn it
like for example the news front page
this is a a slice from it so it has a
local news section which people can type
in their local area and they search
there and bigger like content that's
local to them so while their
accessibility guidelines BBC has these
mobile accessibility guidelines they are
they take likes the actual like standard
body stuff and make it like more
understandable so it's not in standard
written speak it's written like
understandable language and so there are
sections that are wrong
web accessibility and also iOS and
Android so you've got you've got the
verb so you're regardless of what kind
of mobile device project you're working
on and and like at the bottom which is
really pretty cool you might not be able
to see it because it's kind of small
there are examples of how you test
so like procedures like activate the
screen reader and fill out the form and
you check that when you have services
the focus the the focus guide name
checks that the focus doesn't move on to
different things that it actually stays
stable so it only moves when you
actually tab all you press ENTER and
things like that so it has actually like
skier step-by-step guidelines that you
can take so that was tossed area and
after toss area what we did is that we
we wrote down notes oh I wrote down
notes of what happened like did I find
anything were there any bugs did it work
as expected
did it do something that I didn't know
whether it was right or wrong but like I
don't know it did a thing
he's like the good thing or a bad thing
and then I was able to talk with the
head of the team the head of the
accessibility champions team right and
they are able to give me advice but what
about you well if you don't have like a
whole team of like 150 people which is
quite a lot to get advice from there are
other people you can ask there's the web
ally so a 11y select channel which is
like over 2,000 people from around the
world like including like experts that
write likes and some things also like
completely beginners
yes Twitter you there's hashtags I love
my hash tags and as we've heard like
yesterday and the day before these
abilities here based on Singapore and if
any of you are based here or in around
surrounding like Southeast Asia you
should definitely drop the message
because they would like to get in touch
and do to help you out with auditing
your pages okay so you've done a toss
your you've kind of found maybe about
maybe not bug all of that well what do
you do to take just full review of
things how do you how do you manage that
well we've got github repo with all of
the steps that we take for news so that
includes things like information for
developers for designers or if you've
got business analysts in your team for
them if you've got a product donor what
they need to be thinking of right at the
beginning of a product when they're
talking to stakeholders and and
information gathering things like that
so it's a detailed but it's also got
section those views so like for
developers it's got information of like
before development starts what should
you do like tortured tortured signers
about things before things have been
said of certain things like that and
then it's got things throughout
development what should you do
so there are also different levels of
things so on the first day it talks
about limiting I said like 'hey--
assailant there is if you use and then
just round talking about like other
premix so we use react on the server
side and so we use like JSX and yes lint
like accessibility lint so basically
what that does is that if you forget to
put an alt text attribute to explain
what images it like warns you one your
when you're writing on things so you you
find out about errors just as you're
writing so just like you would find out
about mists miss closing bracket as
you're typing and you need to fix her it
tells you like right up front so it
doesn't become like it doesn't build up
to have like a million errors and you
just fix as you go along which is pretty
cool
there are lots of browser dev tools
there's like if you open up Chrome
you've got an accessibility tab you can
do an accessibility to order gives you
like a score of 100
she's just give me or like a that gives
you hints in terms of what you should be
looking at this there are online pages
until so you can basically put the URL
if it's already live if your products
already live you can put a URL into
there and it can give you give you a
review there there's manual testing with
devices so you I'm pretty sure if you're
all web developers you've got a mobile
phone or a laptop of our device there
open up there and and and you can use
pretty much all iOS and Android and and
Macs and everything they have in Bell
screen readers you can test out there
and if you're not sure about how to do
that on this URL there are like
instructions about how to how to step
through that and get started okay so
that's kind of what you do when you like
if you're kind of by yourself you're not
really sure like and you want to get
started and things like this but what do
you do if you're in a larger team so
this is a few techniques yes so this is
kind of like when you've got when you've
convinced your manager this is a good
thing but you can do this on the sly
which is
get in so accessibility swarms and it's
not as terrifying as it sounds it's
really quite fun
it's basically so this is the photo of
like a fearless the developers in our
team singing abuse with all the devices
out on the table so like a laptops
accessibility laptops phones the
developer who's like you're taking the
selfie was using Dragon Dictate so a
software that you can talk to at it and
it take navigates you through the
through the page so you don't need to
like use the keyboard or a mouse at all
you could just talk talk and and and
browse the web which is pretty cool yes
so you can do that and the reason why
this is really fun it really changed the
way like we look to accessibility
reviewing products is that it became a
fun activity it didn't become like a
chore that you just like cut it like
tick off with we could merge a code it
became like you like look forward to
like the two hours in the afternoon that
you had had packed in your calendar
because like yeah you get to like you
get to like try other thing and you get
to laugh and you get to like make fun of
somebody like using trying to teach the
dictation software and it can understand
this accent and it's really great yeah
but it's cool because it's like it's
it's a lot of fun and it can make
something that I think a lot of people
think there's quite tedious into a
really enjoyable activity and it's work
these are devices that we have if you've
got budget then you can probably get a
whole lot about the device like yes
if you don't just using what you have is
fine we have a device metrics that we
use so we actually look at what what
devices are most commonly used in the UK
what what assistive tech has miss
colonies in UK because that's why I call
me an audience there and and prioritize
them so we've got like a priority one
level and a priority to level and things
like that so you can go into a lot more
detail rather than if you've got that
the stats for there
and then if you've got a little bit more
budget you can do user research so this
photo is of a user research laboratory
so in London it's got a one-way mirror
which is the coolest thing it was like
so we're so we're sitting on one side of
the one-way mirror and the participants
of the user research are thinking and
the other where the somebody like asking
questions and things why not
ask more questions more like guiding
them and telling them what what let's
use that and the great thing is that as
a result that we get really positive
feedback for everybody so like Nora
senior designer so French now
understands the payment that assistive
tech users of assistive tech can go to
to access content so so that's great
because the thing is is that we want to
like not only is they use the research
good for us to find out what bugs we
have in our software but it's also
really really great so that we can get
more people within our organization to
really understand why it's an issue and
like get on board and feel more be more
be an active advocates for caring about
accessibility to takaka as a developer I
found it really eye-opening experience
and viewing the user research and wanted
to apply it to everyday practice and
finally Allison was the assistant editor
so on the stakeholder side of things so
he invited people from from about who
her on the stakeholders as well as like
in the product team and she thought it
was really interesting to see what
particular problems they face and this
is like invaluable because then next
time and we're talking about why
something we had to like redo a feature
and things because of accessibility they
understand why and they like acknowledge
the fact that that is like that is a
totally valid reason why like you know
the feature is delayed to get get we
delay launching and things and this is
like amazing to get everybody on all
sides of the organization involved and
understanding and positive about
accessibility yeah like over half of us
does like this the first time they're
using tech and pretty much everyone said
that their level of awareness had like
improved drastically so that was a bit
of a whirlwind tour talking about yeah
well I think accessibility is important
what we're kind of doing that BBC and
just brief overviews about what you can
do to get started for free I'll share
the links later and feel free to ask me
questions thank you very much and yes
thank you very much
[Applause]